and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Tim
Dylan is going to hell this is Tim Dylan
we're doing an episode today that
everybody has been a love I think there
might be some people that have a
negative reaction to this episode and
understandably so you know perhaps I
think the reaction of the person might
be negative and that's understandable
but I don't think the reaction to the
conversation will be negative this is
somebody that I've wanted to have on for
a while because I have a personal
history with this person this person has
done many things in his career he was a
co-founder of vice he's had many
different shows and I think many of you
know who I'm talking about and it is
Gavin McInnes and Gavin for those of you
who don't know had a show that a lot of
comedians went on he had our long
conversations with comedians who would
know comedians that were left-wing
comedians that were you know more
right-wing and Gavin was a frequent
guest on red eye and a lot of comedians
would go on red eye and we would all sit
there and yuk it up with Gavin and you
know Gavin has had many differences of
opinion with comics and they were all
done in a respectful way and on my
personal story with Gavin is it I did a
show a few times and I think he was the
one who got me on red eye which was a
show that Tom shaloo hosted on Fox News
and it was at 3 a.m. not the highest
rated show on the network clearly but it
was a show where a lot of comedians
would go on and you know have fun and
talk [__] and basically there was this
weird intersection of comedy and
politics and culture and that's where
Gavin lived I mean Gavin was a funny guy
he was kind of a troll and he was you
know a lot of the you know things he
would do had a performative ass
and of course a lot of people know the
know the story you know about the the
proud boys which was you know in some
people's mind and I think he Gavin's
mind it was you know he would tell you
it was a harmless men's club and some
other people might tell you it's a
violent gang and maybe the truth is
somewhere in the middle and we'll let
him tell you that but for me the story
is about a guy who co-founded a large
media company a billion-dollar media
company vice and a liberal media company
and then now is banned from many if not
all social media platforms I think it's
an interesting story
that's an interesting trajectory for a
career to take when to me knowing Gavin
not well but knowing him you know
somewhat socially it was an interesting
conversation to get into how that
happened and again there's gonna be a
lot of people that criticize my choice
to have a mond you're giving somebody a
platform blah blah blah you've heard all
these arguments before and you know
Gavin still has a podcast is on YouTube
he's somebody that I think has a story
and that that story in and of itself is
fascinating you may hate him you may
think he's dangerous you may think that
the you know proud boys are a violent
organization you might think that he is
a net negative on public discourse and
you might think that he should be
completely shut out of every outlet you
shouldn't be able to speak but the way
that I think about it is that if your
fear is violence and you want a world
that is less violent you can't shut down
all the avenues to communication that's
something that I believe that
something that I think people that I
respect believe which is why Joe Rogan
has had certain people on because he's
having conversations with people you
haven't have said things that I would
absolutely disagree with and I would
absolutely call him out and go that's
[__] and we could have a debate
about it but I don't think simply that
him uttering any of those things makes
me feel unsafe I don't believe that that
is a good way to think about having
conversations and that words and
conversations necessarily make people
unsafe I think that actions make people
unsafe and that's why we have laws we
have laws that protect people and that's
why you have to defend the rights of
people you disagree with and the rights
of people that you feel you feel their
ideas are dangerous that's the reality
Nazis have a right to speak the KKK is
right to speak the supreme court ruled
on those cases not because they like
Nazis but because the right to speak is
a fundamental way and those people have
ideas that are dangerous what happens
more interesting than that I think
there's much more of a gray area here
and I know that we're very uncomfortable
living in a gray area but if I'm gonna
do a show where I talk to people I'm
gonna have to live in that gray area to
an extent and I'm gonna have to make
personal choices and live by them and
the greater is where comedy comes from
okay
great comedy doesn't come from rigid
fundamentalist thinking just doesn't
these are the great conversations a
great discussion you have to be open to
talking to people and that gray area is
I think something that needs to be
explored and I don't think we should
push people into black and white we
shouldn't put people in boxes by the way
this is not to say that I agree with any
of the decisions that Gavin is made and
this is not to say that he doesn't
regret a lot of those decisions but I
feel the same way about Gavin that I
feel about Alex Jones and that I feel
about lots of different people who have
said things that I may consider to be
abhorrent or maybe have inspired actions
that I did
agree with directly or indirectly I
believe that there's probably a lot more
of a gray area then a lot of people are
willing to concede or admit and so it's
in the spirit of that and it's in the
spirit of somebody who makes a living I
make my living speaking into a
microphone whether it's on a stage or
while doing a podcast that is how I make
my living
I can never cheer for the D platforming
of people and I can never cheer for the
silencing of people that's not in me I
was a I was on debate team in college
and I loved arguing with people and that
was part of what I thought the strength
of this country was was that you could
do those things I just can't and I may
you know think that somebody is just
completely helpless meaning that I can't
reach them that logic an argument has
completely failed but at that point you
have to really make a decision and the
decision is you're living in a country
with a lot of people they're never gonna
see eye to eye with you are you going to
coerce them forcefully physically
violently to agree with you or you gonna
adopt some form of live and let live you
know fundamentalist Christians don't
think that gay people should get married
or adopt kids or anything like that you
know am I gonna spend the rest of my
life converting everybody who believes
those things should I am I going to
spend the rest of my life chasing those
people down harassing them making sure
they can earn a living making sure that
they shouldn't be able to have a
business is it a good use of my time on
planet earth is it a good use of
anyone's time and by the way this isn't
to minimize the violence clashes or
whatever that the proud boys have been
involved in I don't I'm not claiming to
have any information about that that is
you know definitive I don't I've said
all groups suck I wouldn't want to be in
any type of Club and I
wouldn't want to be in a club well
you're running around getting in violent
altercations with people that disagree
with you politically it's completely
ridiculous you know that being said I
think this podcast is about a
conversation with somebody that I knew I
had a personal relationship with never
close we didn't know each other that
well but he always treated me with
respect and I went on a show and he said
some crazy [__] things some of them
were very funny some of them were just
very crazy and that person I've seen
spiral out of control and a lot of the
events around him seemed to spiral out
of control and I wonder how much control
he had over some of them and maybe he
had more than I thought I don't know but
watching it and then watching people you
know basically decide that this guy is
Hitler and this guy should never have a
platform and this guy should never be
listened to and there's no curiosity
about what happened and how it happened
and how this guy that you know would sit
down and talk to comedians and goof
around on redeye became public enemy
number one you know and the FBI watch
list and I think they took them off or
they reclassified the prowl boys I don't
really know but watching this stuff
happened and watching this unfold has
been kind of wild to me and I kind of
had a front-row seat for a lot of it not
for a lot of the events that I'm
describing but for the very beginning
just meeting Gavin knowing him going on
the show along with a lot of other
comedians and then just sitting back and
being plugged into the climate that we
live in and watching people get the
platforms and watching what's happened
to Gavin or watching the whole situation
kind of spiral out of control
and you can make your own decision on
Gavin and you can make your own decision
on what he's saying you could if you
find him to be truthful or if you I'm
not my goal is not to be like this is a
sympathetic character it's not to be you
know this is not a PR thing but I just
want to have a conversation with a guy
that I kind of knew about how things got
so crazy so if you mad at me about that
I don't know what to tell you this is
really this is the podcast we've had a
lot of people on the show some of them I
agree with some of them I don't but
everybody I've had on the show I find
that it's either been entertaining or
it's been interesting and if you don't
live a little bit in those gray areas as
a performer or as somebody who
communicates I don't know what you're
gonna do I don't know what kind of show
you're gonna have if you're only gonna
have people on that are approved by the
you know the Twitter mob or by
mainstream media outlets if you're just
going to talk to those people you know
you can have a certain kind of show but
that's never the show that I wanted to
do and those are the stories that have
never really interested me these are the
stories that interest me and so we're
gonna have this conversation at home oh
good you're in an undisclosed location
yes like genial yes how how are you how
are you doing Howard cuz I know that
you've had a lot of you've been you're
off all these things and it's gotta be
for a guy like you who this is your
whole career this is what you did for a
living for years is communicate with
people is this driving you nuts you know
I started this I started vice in 1994
I've been doing this a long time and
I've seen all these ups and downs and I
remember you know the PMRC
when it was all about rock and roll and
Twisted Sister are gonna ruin our kids
so this is just one of the many waves
that have seen come and go but you know
I for a few years before Twitter I
didn't have Twitter and I did okay it's
frustrating on a different level though
it's frustrating that the culture has
come to this
yeah and that's that's irritating I mean
I got my new site out now free speech TV
and Twitter that the annoying thing
about not being on Twitter is not not
being on Twitter it's that someone is
controlling the conversation and
deciding who gets to say what and how
they can say it and and that's what's
disturbing it's more like the
cept it's not the actual day-to-day or
me personally I just don't like it yes
as in America and I think you more than
most people unfortunately are unable to
defend yourself against some of the
things that are said about you because I
have arguments with people about you and
they say things like Nazi and white
supremacist and I'm like that's never
been my experience with this guy ever
and I don't know and listen I'm sure
that we disagree on things whatever but
the idea that you're some kind of Nazi
or that you're so kind of white
supremacists or that you hate gay people
or what I none of that Tim from is
anybody's experience that knows you
personally or that it's been on your
show but yet now that you can't really
now that you have no way to communicate
with people they can kind of say those
things about you and you are now you
can't even respond
yeah it's I think that's the plan the
Brian it's uh it all comes back to Trump
at the end of the day the I think that
the left realized they don't have any
candidates they don't have any policies
they should go on infrastructure and
health care or something you know real
but that probably didn't swell with the
kids so they go okay let's be radical
radical Muslims and in the White House
and Cortes saying no more fossil fuels
and abortion the day of babies born
let's just go [__] all-out because
Trump won and he went all out see
they're basically on the assumption that
Trump won by being a Nazi and they go
okay they'll be the anti-nazi but the
wrong about Trump won because normal
people working-class people can identify
with him he's not [__] Nazi dummies
so they put all their eggs on this
basket based on a wrong assumption
ya know so it's the wrong assumption is
everybody we saw with comedians
comedians at work the road new Trump was
gonna win I would go on the road and I
would talk to people and these people
aren't white supremacists they [__]
live in Ohio and they're pissed and
they're the factory they worked at is
gone and their kids are addicted to
opioids and there's all kinds of
problems and they're concerned about
immigration and and and they felt like
they didn't have a voice in the comics
that were on the road knew that and the
comics that were in writers rooms in New
York and LA that only hung out with
really Ivy League millionaires to be
honest that's who's in those writing
rooms we're shocked and those are the
people that when Trump won we're
throwing tantrums and crying and laying
on the floor of NBC and I mean but we
all knew it was was gonna happen what do
you and and most people don't really
know that I think the the proud boys was
like a satirical thing that you did and
it was like I'm a men's club that was
based on a joke really and it was it was
a funny thing the way that it was first
conceived yeah it still is right it's
like it hasn't occurred to anyone that
there's some humor involved but someone
who's patriotic and loves Trump could
also have a sense of humor I mean they
have an offshoot called the margarita
boys right
we're in shirts and only drink
margaritas and they're like the sinister
history of margaritas or they'll always
twist it that way and sorry to finish
what I say about the Trump Nazi thing I
got knocked off track because technology
is confusing me but here's an analogy
right Tim Dylan I'm competing with Tim
Dylan for this local comedy thing Tim
Dylan's doing really well
he got where he is today cuz he's a very
effeminate gay who wears a tutu and his
always danced around and lisping and
he's always got his hands like hey girl
so I'm going to compete with him by
saying I hate [__] and I'm the anti gay
guy right right and then people start
saying
actually that's not Tim's deal at all he
doesn't he's not remotely effeminate and
I go hmm I know I'll just make it
impossible for anyone to say that and to
defend and then I'll just keep going
with this gay suk thing and based on
this false assumption that Tim's doing
well because he's a raging Queen and
that's what they're doing with Trump
they go trumps and not see all right
we're gonna be the anti-nazi and then
people go yeah we're not that we're Ohio
people where Gavin and they go cut him
off cut him off and cut him off I need
to keep pushing this Nazi thing if I'm
gonna win the election so I think the
rest of the country is sitting there
going I've met Tim he doesn't wear tutus
what are you talking about actually no
one wears tutus what are you talking
about and they go shut up banned you're
banned you stop talking about tutus okay
and then they have signs on their lawns
that say tutus have no home here and
you're like what [__] tutus right oh
we were all over Connecticut that's the
shooting a sketch today and there's all
these signs with hey des no home here
and you're like what the [__] you
talking about does rape have no home
here what hate you don't allow Klan
rallies in your house Congrats
wow what a radical stance do you see
though that like there are I think you
know certain parts of the right that are
really invested in and by the way also
on the left that are really invested in
like purely racialized stuff which is
you see it on the far right and you see
it on the far left salon and Slade every
articles
white men sucked pit you know everything
that's ever been done wrong in history
comes from the colonial era of white
guys you see it but you do see that
there are some of those guys on the
right where it's like all about race but
if you look at a photo of the proud boys
they're not white like I showed this
photo as at dinner the other night in
Los Angeles I took a photo and said
these are the proud boys that you guys
call white supremacists they're not
white so if I could continue with this
analogy they just go Tim as hiding his
tutu in his pants it's tucked in there
like the daily beast is that and I would
you know you by the way know I love it I
think it's a good analogy that there was
a the Daily Beast an article in it
what's called multiracial white
supremacy and you go Jesus Christ you
guys just cannot get knocked off these
rails it's it's like this guy's this guy
is a pedophile really he's never been
near kids he's married to a woman ten
years older than him the strange life of
pedophiles or they will date a woman and
years older and keep it bottled in and
then they they they go like well really
black immigrants like from Africa are
doing better than blacks or is it really
such a what like why are agents doing so
well for such a racist country or whites
are like seven on the ethnic as far as
ethnic groups as far as success in
America weights our numbers you got
Asians and you know Jews and everyone
way above them African immigrants
Lebanese all above them and then they go
well it's it's not that tangent it's
it's in the air it's it's latent it's
it's invisible it's a microaggression
you go you sound like a weird Puritan
from the founding fathers like the the
the pilgrims you sound like a weird
humorless pilgrim that hates blasphemy
because they to them it's a religion and
you hit them with all this logic and
they just go the strange life or it's
complicated or you know he's races he's
married to a black woman some slave
owners would bang their slaves and
you're like you got to go back 150 years
to find an example of your crazy theory
but when we're all silenced we can't
explain that so they just go yeah
whenever and by the way when people say
bad [__] about me to you just say he
didn't
say that cuz they'll pull up some quote
and it'll be from some liberal source
like the SPLC or Huffington Post and
these are what your enemies think of you
so of course they're gonna take jokes
out of context and of course they're
going to have a biased view like if you
ask the Red Sox fans about the Yankees
you're gonna hear all this horrible [__]
and go the Yankees of the worst
shittiest most evil team in the history
of baseball they don't watch the Yankees
play they just hear the Red Sox version
hello folks
how are you I just had a fillet a fish
and the bun was not steamed and the
steamed bun is the most important part
of the filet of fish the fillet of fish
as you know at McDonald's is a patty of
white fish fried a half slice of
American cheese tartar sauce and a bun
that is steamed which makes it soft so
that when you eat it there's absolutely
no resistance and the entire thing
becomes like a fish cheese tartar really
the consistency almost of like a bread
pudding like a salty dessert and when
the bun is not steamed what I want to do
is grab a ar-15 and walk in there and
and really ask them and I wouldn't hurt
anyone I would just carrying the gun go
let me ask you a question it says on the
menu that the bun is steamed why did we
choose to have a stale bun that ruins
the sandwich I know it's a shitty job
but that makes me think about sex leads
me to my next point
sex cuz if filet-o-fish when done right
is soft supple sexual okay you don't
want a hard bun but you know you do want
a hard [__] hard dick gotta be hard if
it's not you don't want to steamed dick
you do want to steamed bun don't want a
steamed dick okay you want a nice hard
but dick what am I saying so let's talk
about from
okay everybody against digital got the
climax control spray of from messin and
we all sprayed it on our pieces and you
last longer if you want to last longer
most men are not lasting long enough
women take 18 minutes to come men 5 ok
now what are the two answers there
number one you can stop having sex with
women well number two you can get per
messing it's developed by doctors
doctors who said I want to help men go
longer in bed [__] everybody else
Alzheimer's and cancer patients and
infectious diseases in the third world
I want to make [__] spray and those are
the doctors that I think are great they
probably all work in Vegas they have
some institute there and they study [__]
spray because they're doctors and they
took a Hippocratic oath to help people's
lives ok so what you do here's what you
do if you didn't guess how to do the
permison maybe some of you out there is
slow you spray it on your [__] ok you
buy it and you spray it on your [__] not
in your mouth not on her [__] spray it
on your dick ok they use a patented
target zone technology so that this
doesn't transfer to your partner so it
will not jump from your dick to her
[__]
thank God cuz then nobody's gonna come
professing is recommended by over 2200
urologist it's the first line of defense
to last longer in bed it's also the
number one sexual enhancer product on
Amazon shipping is free and discreet
60-day money-back guarantee no
prescription needed no awkward doctor
visit you don't have to go to your
doctor when he goes with you bronchitis
what does he pack you go nut it I had
actually I uh I'm here for the [__]
spray you have the [__] spray can I get
a little [__] spray I get
script for the [__] spray my wife can't
come she needs me to [__] her for 48
minutes before she'll come she lays
there like a corpse and I have to just
[__] her til I'm near heart attack
because this woman cannot orgasm for the
light so I just need to spray my dick so
I don't even feel her I don't even feel
her I don't even know what I'm doing
anymore
I'm just humping this old mass of cells
lying in my bed staring at me praying
the God that I just [__] die that my
heart explodes and blood cascades out of
my mouth onto the face of this
ungrateful [__] but permissive spray
does work very well everyone has said
that go to delay spray calm folks de la
whaai spray i'm not spelling spray if
you can't spell spray shouldn't have sex
delay spray calm use the promo code Tim
15 you look at 15% off your purchase
delay spray dot-com 15% off your
purchase permissive yeah the new thing
now that a lot of people do is they say
well this or that person is anti-trans
now anti-trans is like this you know
it's this description of somebody and
then you go what do you mean by
anti-trans like do i believe that there
are 400 genders no I don't believe that
I I believe that biology and gender a
link that's you know and by the way not
only me that's hundreds of years of
science uh and and also I look at a lot
of what's going on when I see like this
kid is Desmond the amazing kid who's
dancing on a bar and men are throwing
money them I'm like this seems to be
child abuse I'm a gay guy and I'm deeply
uncomfortable with some of what's going
on where I look at this stuff and I go
and I talk to older gay people some of
them are terrified because they can't
say anything because they'll lose their
job
or they were
in the entertainment business but
there's a lot of people that are
uncomfortable and the whole thing is
like the the trance thing of like gender
not not being informed by biology flies
in the face of the gay thing immediately
because if you're a gay guy and you're
attracted to a dude if a woman says I'm
a man it doesn't matter it's like I said
the other night it's like if I identify
this thin if you want an in shape person
and I say I identify as a guy who does
triathletes but you go it doesn't matter
it's there's a biological facts that fly
in the face of what you're saying so one
of the things that people will say about
you is ago will cavities anti-trans and
I'm like well it's not just a entire pro
thing it's a deeply complicated issue I
was like I don't think gavin cares what
private people do in in their homes or
whatever but I think yeah I don't think
Gavin's gonna be forgiving hormones to
kids but neither am i and neither are a
lot of people that I talk to is that
because that seems to be trans seems to
be the new thing it's the new one that
seems to be the new litmus test yeah I
don't know I think they might be
abandoning trans I think they realize
they got into bed with mentally ill gays
and they went you guys are not making
the greatest allies you're [__] weird
so it's moving on yeah who's now now
it's just anyone who's I think women and
people of color like that you see sure
to say the future is female and the left
is now saying if you're a white male
white straight male don't run for office
we don't need you you're done so they've
seemed to focus even Martin Luther King
like he didn't focus on identity
politics enough and they're sort of like
[__] this is a deal it's about being
a person of color a woman or a gay and
trans I don't think trans panned out to
them but to get back to the trans thing
what what i Sai wrote an article about
five years ago called transphobia
perfectly natural and what I was saying
is you're at Thanksgiving your dad shows
up he's Caitlyn Jenner he's dating you
know Caitlyn Jenner's new girlfriend is
like this dude named Sophia who just
became trans and used to be like a ben
shapiro type of kid and he's about 21 so
and he looks like Jar Jar Binks in drag
so because this is [__] weird lips
so your dad comes in he's like hi
everyone I'm a lady
and he's with this 22 year old
dumbfounded Jar Jar Binks just going hi
I'm a lady too we're in love and the
idea that your whole family is going to
not be crying at the Thanksgiving dinner
and just for going hey what's up Katie
hi it's just a [__] lie if your
brother were shows up with tits at
Christmas you're not gonna be like hey
Katie what's going on you're kidding
yourself if you're gonna do that
end god forbid they should get a vagina
well my whole attitude on it is like
listen if you're an adult and you want
it transition good for you I don't I
don't know the numbers of people that
either D transition because there's
supposedly numbers that are pretty
striking of people that are like I don't
know any of that but if you're an adult
and you want to do that would it you
know if you feel if that makes you
happier as a person good but to me the
problem is you cannot give children
hormones to block puberty because now
we're like this is [__] insane and I
get in trouble for saying that and
people don't like that I'm saying that
but I really feel that by screwing up a
child's development it's sick yeah Tim
that's easy though that's easy to say
that we shouldn't give children hormones
and we shouldn't have Desmond Lee
amazing dancing at a gay bar to it
morning where they're putting money in
his pants and he shouldn't be on a
podcast with Michael alig who just did
20 years for dismembering his meth
dealer and he's that desmond is acting
kind of catatonic in front of a painting
that says rohypnol which is a date rape
drug
none of that should be on but I think
that's pretty simple it's pretty easy as
far as the adult thing goes you know
what I bet there's like 17 people in
America that would be better off with
the sex change not house they're doing
here's another thing their suicide rate
is off the [__] charts
it's worse than Jews in 1943 in Germany
they have a higher suicide rate than
that particular
why would why would use killing
themselves in 1943 what wasn't somebody
doing that for them because it was a
horrific time they lost their family and
their children were just killed and
they're live in the cotton I think if a
country went to the trouble to
exterminate a race of people I think
it's pretty inconsiderate to kill
yourself
let's see you can't make jokes like that
anymore I can't worry I'm so in trouble
already for this podcast I figure who
gives a [__] I need it or vote but but
here's the thing I say but the adult
trans thing cuz I hope the kids trans
thing is a given the adult trans thing
is look if it has to happen and and
they're they're suicidal if they don't
do it bla bla ok fine but when we
encourage it what we're doing is taking
normal gays and making them do really
serious permanent things to their body
that they then become suicidal because a
lot of them the they they have problems
like they're bipolar and they're
depressed they think it's all kinds of
this penis or it's all because of these
tits and then they make the operation
and they go holy [__] I'm still
depressed I'm still bipolar it didn't
fix it and they kill themselves so we
have to stop encouraging someone to go
into basically a demographic where
they're Jews in 1943 like why are you
sending all these these gays with
troubles into the death camps that's
what you're really doing and there's
these these radicals in Britain they're
called turfs trans exclusionary radical
feminists and their whole thing is like
why you have they're British why you
having young lesbians cut their breasts
off 7 their breasts like try being a gay
for a while and then get back to me if
you think you're a little a woman and
you're 13 and you want to do something
permanent like take hormones because
let's make you infertile by the way just
become 18 put on some red leather short
shorts and dance around the West Village
for a while I have a feeling that's
gonna put out the fire and you're gonna
come back to me oh thank God I did not
lose this diamond gem between my legs
right yeah I've always said like I I
don't obviously I've spoken to trans
people I know that there are people that
feel better when they have the surgery
I'm sure that that is something so let
me ask you a question you're why in your
estimation cuz you look at this issue a
lot why are your very pro-family
people having children I think you're
right about that I think people should
have children I don't know what people
think you're gonna do with their life if
they don't have children uh why are
people not you know having kids
specifically you know well-to-do people
that live in cities are not really
having kids or that they live in the
suburbs and maybe they have one kid do
you think it's the result of social
engineering do you think it's just that
people have gotten too comfortable and
what what is it that because a lot of
people they stood you know they talked
white genocide and all this stuff and
it's like well no it's just people
aren't having kids they've you know
white people are choosing to not have
children or to have one child families
what is that is that just people that
are yeah it's definitely conditioning
it's definitely cool to [__] on the
family it's definitely in to turn women
into colostomy bags for everyone's come
and they're just a booty call instead of
a loving mom but there is a genetic
component to it it's part of God's
design for some strange reason I haven't
figured out but you see this like even
in Mexico their GDP is going up they're
getting a larger middle class they're
they're their standard living it's going
up and as their standard of living goes
up their birth rates going down same
with Japan as they get more affluent
their birth rate goes down I don't know
why he put this in the program but for
some reason when we get to a certain
level of wealth we cut down the kids
it's a miserable thing to do I mean I
had three I started at 36 and I just
look at them and think [__] why did I
wait so late and why did I can't have
more now my wife's ancient but I I wish
I had five what the [__] have I done and
I want to tell this to all these other
young women that you know outside of
this genetic trait that makes rich
people not want to have kids cuz I don't
know they're too rich I want to say
you're going to regret it like that's
the other thing with my whole crusade to
have kids it's not like I've anything
about demographics of the population or
white genocide or any that [__] it's I'm
48 and I've see all these women go what
have I done I see them spending 20 grand
on fertility drugs
I was one of those people that said the
world's overpopulated and we don't need
kids we don't need more people then you
look up the population on on your
computer and you see it go like it goes
up so you're not having kids is not
making a [__] difference from you
logging onto that website to you logging
out there's been another 150 kids what
the [__] are you doing with your one
grain of sand on the beach changing the
world so I just want people to stop
regretting it because I see these older
woman these older single women and
they're [__] miserable they've got
their cats
they're in denial you know I yeah I saw
this woman we were talking about on the
show where she had adopted a chicken and
you're not allowed to have a chicken in
Manhattan so she moved out to the
countries where her and the chicken can
be happy
I mean it's [__] percent and she's
like he likes to read the paper with me
and he likes to make the bed lady he's
scratching your bed because he thinks
it's the ground cuz he's trying to get
seed because he's just instincts that's
not your child it's a [__] chicken
folks you know I don't know how many
times I have to tell you about wicks I
think every episode for the rest of my
life um so I try to always I try to
always get into these you pay for I
don't phone in the ads I know a lot of
the shows you listen to phone in the end
they make a lot more money than me by
the way they don't care they don't care
they take it in and out quick boom buy
this buy that take this take that give
me money [__] me stuff my throat with
money because I'm a podcaster and I got
ads they get in and out they don't value
you I've al you you I only bring you the
breast products [__] spray CBD oil
online suicide counseling I bring you
the best things the things that you need
we have done tests my audience is
impotent and suicidal so I bring you
these things and you're anxious you need
to calm down that's where the CBD comes
in and
have websites we also figured that out
and we think all the other problems stem
from that they don't have any
self-respect they have no self-concept
they're not fully actualized human
beings why why because they do not have
a place to park their content period
they're playing a social media game
you're on Twitter on tick-tock you're on
the gram you're on Facebook fight with
your aunt you're in a secret Facebook
group I don't know what you're doing out
there but all of that
fine
you need a website you need to have a
place that is professional where you can
link where you can do business where
people can sign up for a mailing list
where you can do all of those things
link people to your social media
accounts sell things all of the things
you need to do you have to do it and you
need to use Wix hundreds of millions of
people have made websites using Wix they
have 500 unique templates to choose from
they have an artificial Adi program
where you answer a few questions about
your website yes I am a hairstylist and
I go door-to-door and I cut the hair of
veterans that have been maimed in Iraq
and Afghanistan if that's what you do
and it's what you [__] should do you
piece of [__]
stop going to Beverly Hills and trying
to you know be a fancy hairstylist go
and cut the hair of the and you say oh
well a lot of those people don't have
hair don't start with me and shave their
balls go shave the balls of people that
serve this [__] is this I get lost
because I care ok if you're a hair
stylist who specializes in cutting the
hair of veterans you need a place to
advertise that skill that's your
vocation that's what you do if you are a
DJ that only plays autistic kids parties
with very non-threatening relaxing
melodic melodic music it's melodious so
they don't get all freaked out you can't
bring a clown in there it'll be chaos so
you're a DJ and you play parties for
autistic children you need a website so
people can find out you have that skill
if you are a tarot card reader and you
go to wealthy areas and read tarot cards
for white women
whose husbands are coming in there
twenty-year-old interns all day and
those women are lost they're lost on
this earth they don't know what's going
on and you need to flip over a few cards
and tell them it's gonna be okay
you need a web [__] site if you're a
stand-up comedian you don't need a
website actually you don't you really
don't
no one cares you need a gun folks go to
Wix don't go to actually go to Tim
Dylan's di ll ons going to hell calm
there is no is in this ti m di ll o and
s going to help calm go to the bottom of
that website click on a link and then
you will go you'll get 10% off up an
upgrade to your existing Wix site or a
new Wix site you'll get 10% off or 15%
don't know you'll get something off okay
it's was it a never enough for you
people you'll just support the show get
a website you don't have to use it do I
give a [__] what you do sign up forget
you have it
I joined Planet Fitness seven years ago
I've spent $8,000 I've never gone I went
once I went once in Queens it's a judge
five treadmills on everyone's in a burqa
and me who should be in a burqa so my
point is this get a website and cut the
[__] okay I don't we don't need you're
complaining that you can't get your you
can't get your name out there nobody
knows about your special skill you're
all special out there like the great
Gary van you're Chuck says you've all
got a business inside of you it's
usually human trafficking but you've all
got a business coz you're all special
talented and unique that's right all of
you every member of my audience is a
special talented unique per
person who deserves to prosper and I
want to help you do that
so get go to the [__] timberlands
going to hell
click on the link can you do that can
you do that while you chew your mouth
off because you're coming down off
whatever drug you ingest to get through
the day sober up folks
that's another add I want to get in
business with one of those sober houses
where they just stuffed the beds and
they they actually help the people
relapse I read about that scam that just
give drugs to people and go just sign up
for the thing and then relapse we need
the insurance money I really want to get
involved with that but I don't know how
and if you know how DMing um Wix it's
good thank you when you look at what's
happened to fight you start advice and I
think it was a Canadian magazine in like
the 90s late 90s 96 something like that
94 94 um when you look they've grown
into this media empire but they're very
big I think you would agree that they
are you know clearly a left-wing you
know you know social justice
you know conscious organization when you
first started that magazine did you
dream or imagined that it was going to
be what it ended up being or was it
because you guys were the counterculture
when you started the magazine you were
offensive you were aggressive and crass
and and now vice to me and you correct
me if I'm wrong they seem very
mainstream they don't really seem like
they're counterculture at all well let
you say the proud boys started out as a
joke and then it became sinister no it
started out as a joke a fun silly Club
it still is it's the water buffalos from
the Flintstones but the media's
perception when they're so desperate to
show that right-wing violence is a thing
they focus on that and they takes it out
of context and they just out-and-out lie
my buddy Jeff is going in prison to jail
tomorrow for 30 days because he fought
back against an Tifa when they ambushed
him and there's no victim nante foe
refuses to press charges but it's become
politicized and he's going to spend 30
days in Rikers
because of this [__] propaganda and
his lawyer saying look dude I've never
seen this before the guy's a cop sorry
the guy's dad's a cop 35 years in the
force he's never seen it before and he
goes something you pissed off the wrong
person and this trial makes no sense I
don't even want to go to trial because
the facts aren't making any impact here
this isn't about that but um yeah Vice
is very different though so the brown
boys have stayed the same but the
perception them changed on October 12
same with my life by the way things were
very normal up till October 12th where
someone flicked a switch when I did this
talk at the Manhattan Republican Club
the same night that that guy got in a
fight and is now going to prison
tomorrow
sorry jail prison is more than a year do
you think that first do you think that
person had flipped a switch if you had
to guess do you think that that person
or group of people had it out for you
were they waiting with a were they
looking for the opportunity to knock you
off all these social media someone a
high up but the DNC said look the
midterms are coming up we're known as
unhinged and violent we have to shake
that rep or we're gonna lose and then
two weeks before I had my talk I said
put all the eggs in that basket get a
fight going we need some sort of
violence event and they were picking
fights they were attacking people
they're getting arrested all day they
they vandalized the venue before that I
mean there was so much [__] going on
before and I've talked to that Club a
million times and there's never any
problem but this night it was like
banners and flags and and when the
police dispersed the group they ran
around the block and then jumped these
broad boys who were on their way to the
train to go home you think and then
think like auntie fuzz taking orders
from the DNC yes that's been
well-documented okay the antics are the
are the paramilitary wing of the DNC
there they're there their shock troops
and it's funny because the DNC couldn't
give less of a [__] about them like
they'll hire them a good lawyer
occasionally but at Mike's turn which is
a night for freedom Antipa showed up and
got it in their heads that there was
Nazis everywhere some old Jewish guys
leaving the event they jump on him start
strangling him he has goes into cardiac
arrest the cops come up they start
fighting the cops the dude who did this
he's gonna go away for 15 years again
this goes back to your tutu it's
all based on a myth so people are going
to jail all over the place for this
[__] lie
but anyway vice really different thing
vice I think retained because I
controlled all the content until the day
I left in 2008 and I think it maintained
that edge in fact I had all kinds of
rules like the sales team can't be on
the same side of the office as the
content they have to always be
adversarial and not get along because
that's selling out is when they the
average advertising gets in bed with
editorial the day I change the sales
team took over and I believe they went
SJW because there is no dollar like the
babysitter dollar there's no money like
girls 14 to 20 so whatever they believe
in and what do they believe in total and
utter horseshit about [__] gender [__]
milkshakes and why some pedophiles are
not bad people and you shouldn't judge
them and why all guys are jerks I mean
all this white male stuff is really just
like guys are jerks you guys it's like
catty sixteen year olds now you as is
taken a toll on I know that you probably
do a lot to just keep you know to keep
to normalize everything that's going on
but like is taking a toll on your wife
and you know I mean like this whole idea
that you know hate is no home and people
putting these signs on your lawn is your
wife ever like what the [__] did we sign
up for did she ever will your yeah it
was it was really bad for a while but
I've always been trying to red pillar
she's voted for Hillary she's pro-choice
tons of frustrating stuff and this is
amazing this is what people talk about
you and they talk about you like you Amy
and you you're married to a woman who's
not white who's a Native American and
she voted for Hillary and she's
pro-choice yeah and I you know I are
good with her so much during the
election I was like look the country's
going in a direction and you're choosing
two different directions if we were all
gonna move somewhere we'd all have to
agree to a move to the same place are we
all gonna move to Colorado okay I can't
move to Colorado and then you're over in
Detroit which is
you're headed by the way with this
terrible decision but I couldn't change
your mind but when I was getting
pilloried everyone was so shitty and
there they were being such consummate it
that it converted her now she's not pro
Trump by any means but she's totally
lost faith in the left because they
terrorized her and her parents and my
parents and my brother like it was just
[__] insane they put posters all over
my kid's school calling me a Nazi they
put a banner over the highway that leads
to my town there was they would harass
people who did business with me bankrupt
them harass bars harassed the landlord
of the bar where I had a beer and I just
said to everyone I got on this message
board that the locals use and I said
come to my house you have a problem with
me you know and we'll discuss it tell me
the thing I said and about 15 cool
people came by I mean the trouble with
that kind of thing is you're at war with
the incurious
and the incurious are never gonna come
by and ask you they want their little
villain it's a silly little game for
them it's fashion but what about this
argument that I don't put any credence
in this argument but this argument that
people go and they find you and then
they end up down the line at David Duke
cuz this is the argument that people
make and it's a stupid argument because
it's like it's the ultimate slippery
slope argument but a lot of people say
they they get in the door through people
that are more reasonable and then they
they're out the door and they end up
with David Duke and Holocaust denial and
all of that stuff yeah well if you check
out the Klan and a lot of you know
serious racists in the south and you
check their record collection I'm sure
you'll find a lot of country music so we
should outlaw country outlaw outlaw
country especially because that seems
prominent in their record collection we
should also outlaw marijuana because
it's a gateway drug and it could lead to
heroin and and more serious drug did you
see that front page of The Times on the
weekend it was like youtubers lead to
the radicalization of yeah yeah that's
what I'm talking about yeah and he's
like I was looking at Gavin McInnes or
whatever videos and then the next you
know I was looking at harder stuff like
Jared Taylor and and [__] like that and
then the algorithm
me too this liberal woman who was
mocking them and now I'm a liberal and
you're reading going wait a minute
this article contradicts itself The
Smoking Gun here is that the algorithm
corrupted you but you just said the
algorithm brought you to liberal and now
you're a liberal so he hammered out all
these ideas and now he's a normal
liberal dude what the what is the point
of this article and it's cited like a
Muslim woman as one of the things that
that that radicalized him he was radical
for like an hour too and he admitted he
was never alright and then he admitted
he's watching this Muslim immigrants
videos and she herself spoke out about
the article and she said wait a minute
I made someone hate Muslim immigrants so
I made a video that that made someone
hate me or my videos that shitty that
you come away from the going I hate that
[__] I really was yeah so so half-assed
and here's the other thing so that a
that isn't true but be say it was true
what's the solution that you hide ideas
who these ideas or dangerous ideas are
never dangerous if you want to present a
long argument to me on my babies are
sexy go [__] nuts and I will point
out that you're insane I can give you a
million reasons why babies are not
sexual but it's not it's not a dangerous
idea it's a disgusting notion obviously
and if the act has ever carried out that
person should be executed but this idea
that there's these dangerous ideas and
dangerous words that's Victorian England
that's the new Puritans that's the
pilgrims I'm talking about whether they
say don't go over there don't go into
that layer it's the danger layer and all
you end up doing too is making as more
salacious and interesting advice you
think that when you look at what's
happening in Europe and you have you
have a lot of migration you have a lot
you have the refugee crisis you have all
of these things that are kind of deeply
upsetting the dynamics of those
societies and then you have to a lesser
degree some of that happening in America
but it's nowhere near or near you know
one we have one percent Muslim
population now within that population
and liberals don't get this word there's
a disproportionate number
radicals I mean one in four American
Muslim men between the ages of 18 and 24
think suicide bombing is sometimes are
often justified that's really bad and
there's this [__] stat things going
around that says what supremacist commit
as much more terrorism than Muslims and
then you look at their stats and they
include things like some rednecks shoots
another redneck and they happen to be in
the Klan oh that's that's racist
terrorism well no it's not and they
treat the pulse nightclub shooting in
the West Side Highway and all this other
stuff as one incident but even by their
crazy stats just like the New York Times
article you pile them up and it's like
10 versus 9 you go wait a minute you
said that punch of Nazi and Trump's a
Nazi and half the country are Nazis so
we got 50% of the population responsible
for the same amount of tear as 1.1
percent so even by your crazy standards
these people seem to not be blending in
as well as say Sikhs and/or do's and
Mexicans and Armenians and Turks and all
these other cultures Lebanese that just
seem to figure it out after a generation
I'd I think Muslims tend to get more
radical as they shall be like a stark
others grew up pretty normal
well those are not brothers there's all
kinds of things there and there's all
kinds of problems you know in terms of
like you know the FBI knew who they were
and they were potentially working you
know the FBI might have recruited them
as informants or whatever and double I
mean who knows there's a lot that is
very strange why does the ruling class
in your estimation of have why this
decision get made where they were just
going to go all right everything's gonna
be open borders and the sacrifices that
are made when you absorb these
populations because a lot of it forget
race or religion a lot of it's just
economic the idea that like wealthy
people love to have landscapers and
people doing their nails and tutors and
things like that and they can you can
pay them anything they want they could
kind of abuse them is that what you
think it ultimately is do you think the
ruling class just doesn't care they live
in gated communities they they don't you
need any you know in terms of resources
they're not on the lower end of the
spectrum they don't they're not
utilizing that the types of
in programs they're not in hospital
waiting rooms that are crowded their
kids go to private schools is that
basically what it is they just are no
longer invested in this idea of a
country is that what it is and is that
what it is in Europe to where they just
don't they don't look at this and go
well this is a country where everybody
has to make sacrifices they just go
we're benefiting from this you know low
wage labor and that everyone else can
[__] themselves yeah it's just fashion I
mean this has always been the case with
the aristocrats oh the who loathes are
killing the Zulus and they're attacking
the were losin my heart bleeds for
Africa it's horrible what's happening
over there we're not even going as in
pump if summer Safari this year that's
how bad it is and I'll call it I love
how you call it fashion because I there
is some real truth to the idea that the
majority of people I meet don't know
even what they're saying like especially
in Los Angeles you'll have lunch with
people and they're eating avocado I was
the other day I was having avvocato
toast it's a beautiful day it's in Los
Angeles this guy pulls up he's got a you
know CLS Mercedes and we sit down and
the woman's there and she just got out
of a beautiful BMW and she goes you know
I never knew what it was like to live in
a country that was really fascist but
now I do
and then she called the waiter over and
ordered she goes do they have the
lobster Benedict and I said these people
are out of their [__] mind like they
had they don't even know what they're
saying they don't even know where they
are
fascism is you would be killed for
saying what you just said lady right
we'd all be dead that's the other funny
thing too about all this pro-communist
[__] is you realize that you're the
first to go the entertainers the
creative types the journalists anyone
who have anything to say you're all gone
all the trades guys that you hate
they're doing great all the rich people
they're fine too
they pay off the the guards to not
[__] abduct them you're the one that's
gonna die dumbasses so you think this is
just basically people that are like this
is the fashion of the day here's proof
if someone's bit you might emigrate
we're a nation of immigrants they're
separating families you just go
I kind of have this Jim Gaffigan thing
right where I do this so why did she
like hot back you say you say okay with
the kids being separated okay you tell
me what to do a man and a kid come over
the border
let them go okay so we have no borders
well okay well then arrest them but
don't separate them so kids go to an
adult holding cell is that so you want
kids in jail with other criminals
they're not criminals okay well we need
a holding cell so we have kids and we
have no proof that's their actual kid he
could just be a trick or it's much
simpler than that you just say how many
legals are there in this country now uh
the far-left says it's like 12 to 15
million the right says it's 30 million
but I'll take any answer in there
that'll be fine I once got an answer 8
billion and you realize wait a minute
you have never looked this up you don't
give a [__] but this is all fat if they
haven't looked it up it's fashion or
here's another test they go trump's such
a risk I can't believe over ways me and
you go what exactly what sentence what
did he say that's racist and they'll go
okay always say the exact same thing
they always go everything and you go
okay well then it'll be easy to choose
one just give me one
Oh I mean where do I even start and
basically everything okay so I'll
happily take one open I don't know
everything I mean basically everything
he says and you look [__] you you're
wasting my time you poser you don't
think any of this is [__] true you
are he said things like the Mexican
rapist and stuff like that I mean he's
bi you know why he said they're not
sending their best and he talked about a
disproportionate number of rapists that
are coming over the border illegally
the Coyotes who take these women over
about 80% of them are raped during this
rapist part of the culture there it's
just it's a rape culture it's literally
a rape culture this border crossing
thing so if you were to take a sample of
the illegals who cross the border
illegally or a sample of Mexicans you're
gonna find a way more rapists in the
first sample of the guys who crossed a
well but crossing
they are sending criminals that has been
a tactic of Mexico away it's an
unthinking rape is a part of Mexican
culture it might be a part of the
culture of human trafficking and people
crossing the border and people preying
on desperate people you know but I don't
know that there's a part of it and it
all a disproportionate number of
criminals including rapists are also
coming over like don't you think if if
Canadians were getting raped as they
cross the border there'd be more
indignation if it wasn't a normal thing
it is a normal thing not in Mexico but
in that particular graphic that's
crossing over and the Mexican
authorities have been very vocal about
the fact that they want their bad guys
to go up there it's it's a free prison I
don't have them in my society you deal
with my garbage right well I am Pro
Canadians getting raped as they come
into the country I think that's they
should have to before they get here just
just to chill them out but are you
disappointed with Trump at all I mean
there's a lot of people on the right and
Colter famously who's like he's done
nothing he's employed his kids
the you know the whole thing has
basically become kind of a weird you
know kleptocracy in a way he's making
money and they're doing business deals
but nobody seems that confident you know
that the walls not being built like do
you look at this and go he's a fraud
he's a huckster we all got sold a bill
of goods or do you look at it and go you
know there's other extenuating
circumstances for why he hasn't gotten
any of this done where do you fall are
you one of these guys who's like well
I'm gonna endorse Andrew yang now or how
do you feel I still have faith but I
Ana's right about just about everything
that comes out of her mouth I still have
faith in the wall she's given up on the
wall
she hates Jared Kushner I couldn't agree
more
that's something the left doesn't
understand my kids get Mad Magazine and
they're very left-wing and there's all
this anti Ivanka anti Jared stuff in it
and they think it makes Trump people get
mad we [__] hate Ivanka why is your
daughter in the White House we didn't
vote for Hillary because we said it's
just a good president's wife who's next
is cousin and then the daughter of the
guy we elected because we hate
monarchies starts pulling in his [__]
son-in-law and his stupid [__] daughter
what the [__] is she doing there
at least the boys she keeps him you know
they can talk to the median stuff but he
doesn't get them an extra billion volved
in the government that that that's not
what we voted for so on the downside I
would say I'm disappointing the wall I
don't like the children getting involved
on the upside the economy is on [__]
fire it's never been black unemployment
hasn't been this this perfect since
slavery do you think he do you think
drop you know I would laugh more it's
when we laugh at the same time the sound
disintegrates but I've been laughing at
a lot of what you said you don't know
yes I'm laughing at everything you say
but the it's because we're forced to
[__] communicate I feel like it's
pirate radio like we're talking through
[__] weird plastic cups and wood that
are attached through you know I mean
it's great how does this deep
platforming thing end does it end where
everybody just goes and sets up what you
set out which is free speech TV we're
talking a little bit about this before
you came on the show and I know meelo is
with you to my love--my law is it Milo
or Mila number one smiler okay I lo so
MA Milo's on there with you and is this
the future for everybody or do you think
YouTube and and Twitter and these things
Facebook or whatever is the future this
week because I talked to somebody and I
said you know the future is just gonna
be people arguing and fighting for
forever and somebody said to me know all
of these tech companies are trying to
eliminate all that they don't the future
is just gonna be serene in in in a
corporate sense in the way that like you
know it's just basically you walk into a
room and it's quiet and you can say
things that are approved and they're
they're shoving ads for products down
your throat but do you think you can
save any of these tech companies or is
this just over and everybody's gonna
have to just get their own situation
well that's a great question and neither
is okay neither of those outcomes are
really good I mean I can afford to I
have a big enough following that I can
charge people and then make enough money
that I can have a studio and
and you know invite guests and go do
other stuff that's what a fraction of 1%
of the population what are the other
people do they can't charge $10 a month
for someone to go hear them and to go
have discussions with other people so I
don't think the everyone has a website
is is such a great solution because not
everyone can do that and say you're some
guy that nobody knows
then you're you've got like Bobby
Daugherty calm and you're just posting
there and no one's seeing it whereas
with Twitter you could comment on
someone's thing and people would get to
know you and it and it was much more
democratic that way and then the other
solution where okay you can go on
Twitter if you talk like you're in a
corporate setting that's not America
that's Soviet Russia that's North Korea
that's China
you know how America was born the Brits
made the huge mistake of insisting that
the whole East Coast had all these
different newspapers and they insisted
that there was dissent amongst the
papers and there was a right-wing paper
and a left-wing paper and that was dumb
because people started getting to know
the truth and started figuring out stuff
and eventually someone goes why are we
even letting the Brits run us like why
are we sending money to some King across
the ocean then they had a revolution and
they want to became America so in
actually linked to the history of this
country the whole formation is it's
about arguing we're in arguing country
we're figuring it out we're of an open
discussion free speech country and to
take that away and have to speak in code
like already
I heard today we always say clown world
when we talk about how insane shit's
gotten and how shoelaces are racist and
it's sexist to open the door for someone
we go this is [__] is this peak clown
world like my babysitter's boyfriend
just dumped her because she works for me
so her dad has told her and you can't
you can't date her anymore meanwhile by
the way if my dad ever told me who I can
date I would laugh in his face and don't
look up right but anyway that's clown
world and other people now clown world
is getting banned so people have been
just saying honk and now honk has become
like a hate speech word so how North
Korean is that you can't say clown world
so you can say honk and then you can't
say honk like an okay symbol can you
see any reason that someone would be
justifiably banned like if their daxing
people if they're harassing or
threatening I mean there's got to be
some line and I agree with you I don't I
don't believe that you could ban
somebody for the things they the
opinions they express but if somebody's
you know going after somebody online and
daxing them harassing them putting their
private information out there I mean
there's there's there's got to be some I
don't know look there's a let's take a
thousand people right I'd say about five
hundred of them are to write a center
five hundred more to leftist Center no
no I wouldn't say that any more as far
as the general no no no I would say that
okay but as far as the media goes though
I would say the media is like eighty
percent on the Left including some
radicals but so it's five hundred five
hundred as far as your average American
right I would say that out of that
thousand there's maybe thirty no no
under that thousand there's maybe like
seven shitty guys Holocaust denying Nazi
Nazi racial identity white genocide
white power all that [__] seven right as
far as the far left though with all this
like white people needn't need to apply
to jobs and all that stuff I would say
it's more like two hundred back of a lot
but we keep talking with these seven
people we keep talking to Heather higher
and Charlotte's Ville again and again
and again I when I started a street
carnage my old site I was like total
free speech man I don't give a [__] what
you say anyone can get on here and then
I noticed there were these one or two
dudes that would keep talking about Jews
and the JQ the Jewish Question and what
really happened in the Holocaust and
they were so [__] fixated on it like
Mike cert of it says he goes I'll talk
about Jews like once a month or
something but and I gotta talk about
other cultures too you guys are obsessed
and what those people do is that tiny
percentage was seven out of a thousand
they bomb everyone out they drag the
conversation down I think Twitter did
have a Nazi problem a long time ago
maybe like five years ago and it was
like the picture of the [__]
you like rubbing his hands together with
the big schnoz a cartoon on every single
person and they successfully got rid of
those guys great I mean you can't not
get rid of those guys they are [__] in
the head they they if it rains on their
birthday the Jews did it
the Jews dominate media that you know
they don't talk about the Jews dominate
medicine or any other thing they are
consumed in their [__] boring
so yes you do have to take care of those
but what the the left is done is they
said oh that was successful let's use
that same thing and say everyone's a
Nazi steven crowder czar nazi ben
shapiro was blamed for the shooting at
that synagogue in Philly someone was
saying it's it's that kind of speech
that leads to these synagogue shootings
Alan Dershowitz is called the Nazi he's
been totally ostracized by his friends
this guy has been fighting he fought he
defended OJ Simpson and he doesn't have
the stigma that he gets now for
defending Trump and they've used that
justifiable and true thing Nazis are a
pain in the ass you gotta kick him out
of the party cuz they ruin everything
and they've dragged it in to everyone
now is it Nazi and it's turned Twitter
into that corporate thing you described
where there's just no [__] fun and
you know you watch old TV you watch
Archie Bunker and I honestly think there
was less racism when people could be
racist like at my boxing gym the way
people talk to him is like look at this
[__] Puerto Rican classic Puerto
Rican you know you got a or you know
there we were ordering lunch today and
and what was it yeah one of the burgers
was called Spanish beef and it's like
that's when a Puerto Rican wants to kick
your ass and you got to face him
that's how blacks and Hispanics like I
think that we divided the big divide is
working-class people like you just said
because when you talk to people that
have only been in these situations
within you know in writers rooms or Ivy
League schools they've never worked a
shitty job I've worked shitty jobs I've
worked with people from every country in
the world in New York City and on a tour
bus where everybody would [__] on each
other and and racial humor I one of my
cousin's loads a truck and they all [__]
on each other and that's how people
become friends
when you work at a shitty job in a
working-class environment but I think so
here's my other question to you if we do
recognize that class plays a role in it
is there anything at all about Acacio
cortez that you like or is there
anything at all about the people on the
left that you like some of the piously
it's a tough question to ask you because
you've been through the wringer with
some crazy P you know whatever but is
there anything on the left that you
would say to yourself I understand the
anger and the frustration at at a health
care system that's completely broken
because you know the plutocrat wealthy
whether they are Republicans or
Democrats and it doesn't seem to be a
huge difference and Coulter used to call
them the you know party I think you
might have as well is there anything on
the left that you could you could you
could say you know what that might make
a little sense is there anything that
Acacio Cortez does where you go you know
what she's right about that no she's a
[__] I think she's a pond I think
she's basically her scripts are written
for her she does like she was talking
the other day about overspending in the
with the government the military and she
was eviscerating this group who had been
charging things like $13,000 for a
toilet seat and that kind of thing this
is an old scam that goes back to the 80s
where you go through the invoices of
some of these contractors working
through the American military and you
see like a $700 pen a golden toilet I
mean it goes it goes way back and it's
an example of corruption and I'm looking
at are going hey Alexandria your whole
ethos is the government needs more money
and we have to pay the government more
money and here you are listing how
shitty they are with money how those
spend $700 on a pen I don't want you're
right by the way that this company
ripped off the government I don't want
the government having more money so her
an ill han Almar and the other one whose
name I can't remember the Palestinian
chick I think they're all radicals and
they personify the - to where they go
Trump was a Nazi so we're going to be
the anti-nazis Trump not an isn't a Nazi
so these
three don't make any sense but what's
your name Rashida to leave we're gonna
beat that [__]
so I I don't see any redeeming College
of them I think they're really bad for
actually they're good for Republicans
cuz they're gonna get Trump reelected
but though there's the stupid [__] they
say but the left general that's a
totally different story I mean Cornel
West is his area type erudite he's a
sophisticated thinker he's a true genius
and I I noticed this with a lot of older
liberals like the Berkeley
nineteen-sixties guys who were carrying
the free-speech banners the classical
liberals as they're called and the ones
that speak to the right like Jordan
Peterson and sargon of akkad and Dave
Rubin but even on the you know normal
liberal spectrum like Bill Maher at
least Bill Maher has the courage to call
out his side when so many people are
about like sports with this where they
won't criticize their side Domar wills
will say political correctness is
killing us and I think though there's a
lot of normal liberals out there that
we're not hearing of the go hey Cortez
could you shut up about the no fossil
fuels and how the earth is gonna be over
in 15 years you're making us look like
imbeciles hysterical imbeciles but Noam
Chomsky mark Lamont Hill I mean I get
along with a lot of people on the Left
and that's kind of what I'm doing with
this show I'm saying you all you hear
about is is that we're not seasoned
white supremacist all we hear about you
is that you're [__] children
let's sit each other in a room and what
I find is people actually disagree on
very few things once they all have the
facts like I was arguing with Sarah
Silverman the other day and and she's
like you know there's a real war on
women right now and you criticize
feminism and I go and she talked about
the rapist law where in Alabama where a
rapist will have parental rights after
she's forced to have a child and I'm
like Sarah you don't you don't talk to
people on this side we hate that rapist
law we think that's [__] mental
that's very esoterical and as far as
abortion being anti-woman almost 50% of
women in this country are pro-life so
it's not a woman
and thing it's a nice lickle question
about when the thing is alive
you know women aren't allowed to shoot
people in the head and that's not taking
away their choice and I I think the
problem with with with her and a lot of
little and she's a great person by the
way with a good heart and so are a lot
of these annoying people like I used to
be friends with Samantha B you should
see her with her kids she's the best
mother ever super funny too like I'm
gonna call the cops is to me monkeys
jumping jumping on the bed
quality people David Cross when we used
to hang out all the time when he had he
was making tons of money at the time and
he'd go on vacation and then make sure
the money he spent on vacation he also
donated to Wounded Warrior Project so
the idea that all these liberals are
stupid [__] is is something I want
to get over and the idea that all right
wingers are Nazis is something that I I
want to disprove to I I don't even
believe in views I remember it's at
FoxNews once in this black dude comes up
he's like yo man I don't wanna an editor
there and he's like I don't really agree
with anything should you say but I
respect the fact that you have the balls
to say it and I'm like dude well what I
don't have views give me a bunch of data
and I'll come up with a general
hypothesis based on this data
you show me a flaw with my data or you
have different data I'm changing my mind
like if cops really were assassinating
black people let's let's go [__]
daunt some cops this is horrible but
then you look into it you go no that's
not really a trend you're lying and
you're actually getting cops killed by
lying that they're hunting down people
so way to go with Ryan but I I think
we're all on the same page I like will
never agree on music will never agree on
food those are all tastes but as far as
political policy it's just a matter of
getting all the facts and talking to
enough people getting a know enough
people so the final question here cuz
we'll wrap it up and then I want you to
tell people about what you're doing
where you're not sure what your name
what your new show is and what you're
trying to do with it but the final
question is like what do you see the
future being do you think this do we
stay at each other's throats in the way
that we've been or is this gonna abate
cuz the way I hate my business used to
be about having fun
and it used to be about making people
laugh and that's why I got into it I'm
not really a political person I like
having fun political arguments but I'm
not a I'm not a [__] ideological
person because that's boring that's what
[__] boring people do that's what my
parents and you know it's like I want to
just go issue-by-issue because I want to
be funny and I want to poke holes in
things and if I have a religious view
about certain things that's gonna make
me less funny and you see a lot of bad
comedy right now coming from people just
the way that you know super evangelical
Christians would probably have a problem
with with or fundamentalist Muslims or
anyone would have a problem with with
with certain types of comedy because of
fundamental you know fundamentalist
attitude is not a great it's just not
good for thinking and that's what you
need to be funny
so does this ever abate or because this
is just there's so many [__] people
now and I've always said politics is
like it's become a refuge for
uninteresting people and no matter what
people can say about you you're an
interesting guy but there's a lot of
people out there where you can tell that
these Twitter fights that get in this is
their entire life they have nothing else
going on they have nothing else to offer
so does this ever abate or does this
just continue forever and ever and ever
well it's gonna keep getting worse and
that's I'm just a natural fighter I
think it's the Scots
that you know they got terrorized by the
English for seven hundred years and it
just bred a bunch of people that like to
brawl the ones that don't like problems
are dead and so I'm gonna keep fighting
this I'm gonna keep trying to bring
people together you know Charles Marie
predicted all this [__] in his book
coming apart he said we're getting more
like Britain where there's like the
elites and the working-class and nary
the to show meat and then you start
building up rumors and myths and and and
lies about either group and then they
get even farther apart and they're just
in these bubbles where that side is
[__] nuts I hate these it's the
Yankees in there and the Red Sox but
when they start going after comedy it
goes from just wrecking the party
because that's what political
correctness has done so far it wrecked
movies where all these girls have to be
kick-ass and beat up everyone and it's
just boring to watch and Star Wars is
all about 700
types of heroes so no one's feelings are
hurt and and then it it ruined music
where all these bands are getting kicked
off labels like in Austin alone I know
of three bands that have had their
careers decimated for saying something
considered to be unacceptable but when
they start attacking comedians that's
when it's getting dangerous or pundits
like me
we are the valve releases on the
pressure cooker it's like cops cop if a
cop has to pick up a body part like say
someone jumps in front of a subway the
cop has to put all those parts in a bag
and sometimes he'll pick up a human head
and be like hey this really does feel
like a bowling ball
he's now sane right he let that release
they can laugh or they'll cry they're
really coming down on the NYPD now and
they're they're castigating people who
make inappropriate comments and cop
suicide is going up because there's not
those release valves but when they get
rid of the comedians and they get rid it
rid of the weirdos the Laurel Umar's the
Gavin McInnes is the the Milo's then the
the pressure keeps building and building
and you end up with a lot more animosity
and stress and tension and you end up
with a sort of a monolithic Soviet
Russia where people aren't happy like
free you know it's think with this the
other can I say the N word on your show
I mean at this point absolutely okay so
that's to say the N word everybody I
just want to let everyone know I want to
prepare them trigger warning if you get
triggered if you've never heard a rap
song if this is the first time you've
heard it go for it leave the room so is
that californica used to have this joke
and he said this there's this one where
people I mean I love Arabs and I would
never use a derogatory term for them but
there was a word that some use to
describe people from the Middle East and
it's a human hate saying and it's sand
[__] and I I would never ever say a
word like that well I mean I might like
here in America I might be like hey get
off that sand [__] this is my Beach
you know you're not allowed on this on
this boat of the beach and he doesn't
say that joke anymore and he can cease
regrets ever saying it but if you really
listen to that joke it's a parody of
racism like Michelle Phan aqus doesn't
own a whites-only Beach there are no
whites only Beach
in America so you're mocking the
absurdity of racism and what it must
have been like you know in this 50s and
60s when I guess they did have the you
know those segments on I guess I know
they had those segregation so he doesn't
do that jokey avoids that so now you
can't Lampoon racism so the irony of all
this censorship and political
correctness is in the in the urge to
save people from evil and bigotry and
racism you're actually preventing it
from being lampooned and that gives it
more authority and strength so I think
these these groups and all this all this
crusading is actually creating more hate
and more racism and back when we could
all joke around you know they didn't
have power I've talked to people who
were molested and they told me there's a
common thread with their stories and
they say once I started laughing at him
it stopped because he lost all his
authority and I remember one night I was
tan or whatever and I pointed him I just
started laughing and then he was
mortified and left the room and he never
touched me again we need to be able to
laugh at evil or it will Fester and and
Pama gate is that ironic right I don't
know but I will tell the n-word is a
word I know that I don't know prompt I
think pramukh it isn't work - they're
both words I appreciate you coming on I
think I really think that this we're in
a weird place because I know some people
I don't think a lot of people get mad
that you came on by the way but I think
some people say oh you're going on a
platform that's what they always say and
it's crazy because they're giving you
[__] for talking to someone yeah and
it's just like I I just don't think that
that way of thinking just goes to such a
[__] not only a bad place but an
uninteresting place it goes to a boring
place and to me as a comedian as
somebody who talks like who the [__]
wants to be boring and who the [__] so
I appreciate you coming on I will come
on your show whenever you want I will
absolutely do that and what is your new
venture what is the new site
proliferate was the word I was okay
think pomegranate got in there and it
changed the whole thing the new site is
free speech TV and it's like pros and
cons progressives and conservatives
coming together seeing what they agree
on first and then they can argue later
and see what they disagree on and it's
going great we've had a wait Cornel West
and no me stand my low you na police we
had mark Lamont Hill and Roger stone
we're gonna have an Coulter Cynthia
Nixon Michelle Malkin uh I forget who
she's paired up with but it's a liberal
doctor guy Noam Chomsky I think we're
gonna we're gonna get Candice Owens
always a liberal and conservative always
civil always quieted so wasn't a bar and
the theme is like it's like I speakeasy
cuz because free speech is prohibited
its prohibition so we sneak in there and
you say you're your secret code and you
can go in there and and listen and the
cops show up and we have to run out the
back but then I also do other stuff on
it just to you know in between all those
sit-down interviews where I I do a daily
sort of a news thing where I talk about
what happened that day and make fun of
movies and videos and I also go through
all my old records and talk about
various bands and then we do sketches
and and I fought this dude coppercab who
is a giant beast but punched like a baby
girl huge variety so free speech TV if
you guys want to check that out your
podcast is called get off my lawn and
it's on Apple podcast for at least
another 15 to 20 minutes and then and
then you're on YouTube and um I listen
man people got to start talking and
people got to [__] relax
well it you know when you and I get
together it's content laughs and you
listen to this particular episode and
you'd think we both worked for the
Senate or something no you know this
yeah let's all be serious and it's not
you and I when we talk normally we don't
talk about [__] global warming or
censorship we're like making fun of
people's pants and they've stripped that
away from us no and but here's the thing
when we do your show or when I come out
to sea it'll be totally different the
tech was an issue here because if we
laugh at the same time or talk at the
same time this whole thing disintegrates
but I think this was a good
so - because there's a lot of people out
there who don't know who you are or that
have heard these crazy things and you
come on here and you make arguments now
they could agree with them or disagree
with them but you're like I'm gonna get
[__] for saying this but you're like
you're a rational reasonable guy
and I don't know I mean I don't know
what else people could disagree people
gonna go no I disagree with them on
trans people I disagree with them on
that but the idea that you're like
carrying a torch making people unsafe is
not the case and I think it's that type
of stuff that people will listen to this
episode and they will hear but I I agree
with you I think hopefully the next
thing we do better tack funnier yes yes
mmm
I'm not just talking about this podcast
I'm talking about the climate in general
like when Sarah contact me I hadn't
spoken her in years and she's like hey
remember that funny thing when that guy
wreaked and whatever and what are you
doing the prow boys is that kind of
racist what's going on there and I'm
just like look here's what's going on
people are going to jail and I got super
heavy into it instead of just being fun
and happy because I don't know I feel
like we're in a [__] war zone and and
when I first talked to people or what
I'm making something public like this
you just have to spend the first hour
debunking myths and then you can relax
and go so anyway who farted right right
well the myths are debunked I mean it's
I mean I mean that's you know we've done
it is Sarah gonna do the show so
hopefully she'll do the show that you're
uh that you're doing yeah yeah it's a
possibility
I you know with someone like that you
don't want to ask cuz you know that 100%
of time when she talks to someone they
go can you come on my podcast right so
I'll let it fester a bit well listen I
appreciate you coming on man I look
forward to seeing you I will do your
show and I think this is good this is an
education for people and um you know at
the end of the day it's like life's too
short life is about more than politics
folks get over it you know
let's short to be gay don't be gay I
listen Gavin you know that I've said
that more than anything
why are you gay have you seen that by
the way that mean it's like an African
interview and he's like we are sitting
with the head of the LGBTQ first
question why are you gay all right buddy
you're the best
I will look for that meme well maybe
we'll put that meme out with this
episode should it's awesome all right
thanks so much Gavin I appreciate it see
you man